se former au et par le numérique à
l'école en famille ou au travail
la fédération des yvelines de la ligue
de l'enseignement invité hier
partenaires et acteurs locaux pour
échanger sur les enjeux du numérique
le numérique c'est incontestablement une
révolution une révolution à la fois dans
les conditions de travail une révolution
à la fois dans les les potentiels de
développement nous sommes un territoire
qui est relativement bien placé sur le
numérique
et puis pour nous c'est une
diversification qu'on est en train de
réussir
nous avons obtenu le label de la grande
école de numérique pour une formation
que l'on va développer à partir de la
rentrée prochaine sur ce territoire qui
est une formation de développeurs
d'apple m milieux particulièrement
concernés l'école où se multiplient
notamment tablettes et tableaux
numériques la ligue et en partenariat
avec le rectorat de versailles et une
dizaine de collectivités des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine pour un projet ifrane
on voit que de nombreuses mairies aussi
accompagnent ces projets puisque tout ça
c'est de la co construction et c'est
tout l'intérêt de socialiser et puis
d'avancer ensemble partir d'un projet
souvent qui est citoyen et pour la
réussite des élèves pour que demain ils
trouvent un emploi ou une place dans la
vie et que la fracture numérique soit
pas encore une cause d'échec scolaire
est la ligue organisme d'action sociale
et de formation professionnelle
travaillent en collaboration avec 390
associations sur le territoire des
yvelines